how much is bluffing part of the game
huge amount
so yeah i mean maybe actually let me ask
like what did it feel like with the live
or anyone else when it's a high stake
when it's a big
it's a big bluff
um so a lot of money on the table
and maybe i mean what defines a big
bluff maybe a lot of money on the table
but also some uncertainty in your
mind and heart about
like self-doubt well maybe i
miscalculated what's going on here what
the bet said all that kind of stuff like
what does that feel like
i mean it's
i imagine comparable to
you know running a
i mean any kind of big bluff where you
have a lot of something that you care
about on the line you know so if you're
bluffing in a courtroom not that anyone
would ever do that or you know something
equatable to that it's it's incr
you know in that scenario you know it
was i think it was the first time i'd
ever played a 20 i'd won my way into
this 25k
tournament
so that was the buy-in 25 000 euros and
i had satellited my way in because it
was much bigger than i would never ever
normally play
and you know i hadn't i wasn't that
experienced at the time and now i was
sitting there against all the big boys
you know the negra news the film ivs and
so on um and then
uh to like
you know each time you put the bets out
you know you put another bet out
your car yeah i was on a what's called a
semi-bluff so there were some cards that
could come that would make my hand very
very strong and therefore win but most
of the time those cards don't come so
that is the same above because you're
representing what are you representing
that you already have something
so i think in this scenario i had a
flush draw to to so i had two clubs
two two clubs came out on the flop and
then i'm hoping that on the turn in the
river one will come so i have some
future equity i could hit a club and
then i'll have the best hand in which
case great um and so i can keep betting
and i'll want them to call but i'm also
got the other way of winning the hand
where if my
card doesn't come i can keep betting and
get them to fold their hand um and i'm
pretty sure that's what the scenario was
um so i had some future equity but it's
still you know most of the time i don't
hit that club and so i would rather him
just fold because i'm you know the pot
is now getting bigger and bigger and in
the end like i jam all jam all in on the
river
that's my entire tournament on the line
as far as i'm aware this might be the
one time i ever get to play a big 25k
you know this was the first time i
played once so it was
it felt like the most momentous thing
and this is also when i was trying to
build myself up you know build my name a
name for myself in in poker i wanted to
get respect destroy everything for you
it felt like it in the moment like i
mean it literally does feel like a form
of life and death like your body
physiologically is having that flight or
fight response what are you doing with
your body what are you doing with your
face are you just like
what are you thinking about
a mixture of like okay what are the
cards so
in theory i'm thinking about like okay
what are cards that look make my hand
look stronger which you know which cards
hit my perceived range from his
perspective which cards don't um what's
the right amount of bet size to you know
maximize my fold equity in this
situation you know that's the logical
stuff that i should be thinking about
but i think in reality because i was so
scared because there's this at least for
me there's a certain threshold of like
nervousness or stress beyond which the
like logical brain shuts off
and now it just gets into this like
it's just like it feels like a game of
wits basically it's like of nerve can
you hold your hold your resolve
um and it certainly got by that like by
the river at this i think by that point
i was like i don't even know if this is
a good bluff anymore but [ __ ] it let's
do it your mind is almost numb from the
intensity of that feeling i call it the
white noise
and and that's just
and it happens in all kinds of decision
making i think anything that's really
really stressful like i can imagine
someone in like an important job
interview if it's like a job they've
always wanted and they're getting
grilled you know like bridgewater style
where they ask these very like really
hard like mathematical questions
you know that's it's a really learned
skill to be able to like
subdue
your flight or fight response you know
what i think get from the sympathetic
into the parasympathetic so you can
actually you know engage the that voice
in your head and do those slow logical
calculations because evolutionarily we
you know if we see a lion running at us
we didn't have time to sort of calculate
the lion's kinetic energy and you know
is it optimal to go this way or that way
you just reacted and
physically our bodies are well attuned
to actually make right decisions but
when you're playing a game like poker
this is not something that you ever you
know evolved to do and yet you're in
that same flight or fight response um
and so that's a really important skill
to be able to develop to basically learn
how to like
meditate in the moment and calm yourself
so that you can think clearly
but as you were searching for
a comparable thing it's interesting
because i you just made me realize that
bluffing is
like an incredibly high stakes form of
lying
you're you're lying
and i don't think you're telling a story
that's that's it's it's not it's
straight up lying
in in the context of game
it's not a negative kind of lying it's
not it but it is yeah exactly you are
you're
i'm you're representing something that
you don't have and i was thinking like
and how often in life
do we have such high stakes of lying
because i was thinking um
certainly in
high-level military strategy i was
thinking um
when hitler was lying to stalin
about his plans
to invade the soviet union
and so you're you're you're talking to a
person like your friends
and uh you're fighting against the enemy
whatever the the formulation of the
enemy is but
meanwhile whole time you're building up
troops on the border
um
that's extremely so hitler and stalin
were like pretending to be friends yeah
my history knowledge is terrible that's
crazy yeah that there were
uh yeah a man
and it worked because stalin until
the troops crossed the border and
invaded
in operation barbarossa where they
this storm of nazi troops invaded large
parts of the soviet union and hence one
of the the biggest wars in human history
uh began
stalin for sure was thought that this
was uh never going to be
that hillary is not crazy enough
to invade the soviet union that they it
makes geopolitically makes total sense
to be collaborators and ideologically
even though there's a tension between
communism and fascism or uh national
socialism however you formulated it
still feels like this is the right way
to battle the west right
they were more ideologically aligned you
know they in theory had a common enemy
which is the west so
made total sense and in terms of
negotiations and the way things were
communicated
it uh
it seemed to stalin that for sure
that
they would remain at least for a while
uh peaceful collaborators and uh that
uh and everybody everybody because of
that in the soviet union believed that
it was a huge shock
when kiev was invaded and you hear
echoes of that when i traveled to
ukraine sort of the shock of
the invasion
it's not just the invasion on one
particular border but the invasion of
the capital city and just like
holy [ __ ]
especially at that time
when you thought world war one
you realized that that was the word to
end all wars you would never have this
kind of war
and holy [ __ ] this this person is mad
enough to try to take on this monster in
the soviet union
uh so it's not no longer going to be a
war of hundreds of thousands dead it'll
be a war of tens of millions dead and um
yeah but that
like
you know that's a very large scale kind
of lie but i'm sure there's in politics
and geopolitics that kind of lying
happening all the time
uh and a lot of people pay financially
and with their lives for that kind of
lying but in our personal lives i don't
know how often we
uh maybe we i think people do i mean
like think of spouses cheating on their
partners right and then like having to
lie like where were you last night stuff
yeah like that's
i think
you know i mean unfortunately that stuff
happens all the time right so or having
like multiple families that one is great
when when each family doesn't know the
other about the other one and like
maintaining that life
there's probably a sense of excitement
about that too
um and or it seems unnecessary yeah but
why well just lying like like you know
the truth finds a way of coming out you
know yes but hence that's the thrill
yeah perhaps yeah people i mean and
you know that's that's why i think
actually like poker what what's so
interesting about poker is
most of the best players i know there
are always exceptions you know they're
always bad eggs
but actually poker players are very
honest people i would say they are more
honest than the average you know if you
just took random
uh random populations for example um
because
a you know i think you know humans like
to have that
most people like to have some kind of
you know mysterious you know an
opportunity to do something like a
little edgy
so we get to sort of scratch that itch
of being edgy at the poker table where
it's like it's part of the game everyone
knows everyone knows what they're in for
and that's allowed and you get to like
really get that out of your system
um
and then also like
poker players learned that you know i'll
you know i would play in a huge game
against some of my friends even my
partner igor where we will be you know
absolutely going at each other's throats
trying to draw blood in terms of winning
each money off each other and like
getting under each other's skin winding
each other up um doing the craftiest
moves we can
but then once the game's done
the you know the winners and the losers
will go off and get a drink together and
have a fun time and like talk about it
in this like weird academic way
afterwards because that and that's why
games are so great because you get to
like live out
our like this competitive urge that you
know most people have
you